what is the world according to Jeff
Goldblum that's a series it's a series
we make 12 episodes of it Nat Geo which
stands for National Geographic these
kids with all their abbreviations these
days everything is an abbreviation don't
get me started
yeah yeah yeah there you go okay anyway
that's my chunk that's why I'm trying it
out of the Comedy Store so yeah Nat Geo
made it's 12 episodes it's me as the
title implies taking you through the
world each week to visit and investigate
a different thing object phenomenon like
ice cream jewelry tattoos my child what
is that yes of course yes of course
those the good guys
there's the good guys the Rebel Alliance
okay okay
anyway things like that I could go on
I'm sure you'd like to one extent or
another all are our things and then I
take you through and I have an
unexpected and interesting ostensibly
account encounter with people you know
in the field anyway and that's it and we
reveal some facts interesting facts
about its history science you know here
and there but really I have these
encounters and my thoughts I excavate
and unspool and share my thoughts and
feelings yeah well you see if you do you
know that's the idea I love everything
Jeff Goldblum doesn't says I love that
cleft in your thank you that's
spectacular yes the highest form of
sculpture I'm gonna call each and every
one
I'm gonna bust some heads if I have to
now let me ask you this because in this
panel we're gonna be talking about what
if which is the show where other Marvel
characters come back in different
scenarios so I'm wondering could the
Grandmaster make a return and what would
you like to see could he could doesn't
mean you should
hey I've quoted myself from another
movie just because he could doesn't mean
he should um yes he might he would he
mustn't but he can
will he that's the question the answer
is maybe I don't want to give away any
secrets you might you know if Taika
Waititi I'll tell you if it were up to
me first of all I love those Marvel I
love all the Marvel people not only the
cast and characters you know the capable
and shots of the world and all and
everybody else but too numerous to
mention but Kevin Feige and Luis
Esposito all the people who run that
place know what they're doing they make
very high integrity and beautiful and
creative supporting delightful movies
but Taika Waititi is a very brilliant
director and a friend of mine now thank
goodness and I love him and would do
anything in any anything that he did and
now he's got Natalie Portman as female
Thor yes I shouldn't say to him all Thor
Thor she's she's Thor I got to hear
about that III well what's Chris
Hemsworth doing what's he he's you know
he gave the keys of the kingdom to
Asgard over to Valkyrie and now she's
trying to find her clean and then
Natalie Portman's Jane Foster is gonna
somehow get the powers of Thor we have
to find out you know more about the
story than I do wow that sounds
intriguing I got to find out about that
I'm I'm eager to know
you